Trascrizione: Mariolina Sanfilippo
Revisore: Simona Donda
Allora, oggi andremo a vedere
il mondo della Generazione Z
per quanto riguarda
soprattutto i social media,
e capire effettivamente
se questi possono essere
un’opportunità o una minaccia.
Prima di tutto andiamo a identificare
cos’è la Generazione Z.
Sono coloro che sono nati
tra il 1995 e il 2010.
Chi di voi fa parte di questa generazione?
(Voci)
Bè, comunque una buona parte di voi.
E infatti, in Italia siamo
8.8 milioni di persone,
quindi, una buona parte.
E, un milione di questi, fanno già parte
del mercato del lavoro.
Questa generazione è la prima che,
effettivamente, è nativa digitale.
Di conseguenza, sa utilizzare
alla perfezione tutti i canali social,
tutti i canali digitali,
e sa esattamente cosa farci.
Non a caso, il 71% di questa generazione
consulta tutti i giorni,
a tutte le ore i social media,
e addirittura un 44%
li utilizza più volte in un’ora.
I due social più utilizzati
sono Instagram e YouTube,
ma TikTok,
soprattutto nell’ultimo anno e mezzo
sta prendendo una grandissima parte
del tempo utilizzato dalla Generazione Z
e sta prendendo sempre più piede.
Chiaramente abbiamo
nuove tipologie di influenze,
quindi, così come in passato
i miei genitori erano molto influenzati
da ciò che veniva detto
e ciò che indossavano le rockstar,
le popstar e gli attori,
oggi, la Generazione Z
è influenzata moltissimo dai Creator,
da coloro che creano contenuti online
e che sono soprattutto gli Influencer,
quelli che noi oggi chiamiamo Influencer,
sono prima di tutto dei Creator,
creano contenuti online sui diversi social
e questo gli permette di influenzare
ogni singolo giorno questa generazione.
Quindi, ad esempio, se Chiara Ferragni
indossa determinati vestiti
farà sì che molte persone l’indosseranno,
soprattutto i micro-influencer,
persone che hanno un seguito
ma comunque creano contenuti online
e riescono a influenzare
una piccola nicchia di persone
che seguono esattamente i loro interessi.
Una nicchia che adesso
sta condizionando molto
e sta influenzando molto la Generazione Z
è quella degli Streamer perché sono
a tutti gli effetti dei migliori amici
di questi ragazzi soprattutto maschi
e che hanno all’incirca dai 13 ai 18 anni,
che passano tutti i giorni, ore guardando
quello Streamer di riferimento
e quindi se quello Streamer utilizza
una determinata maglia,
beve determinate bibite,
o usa una determinata sedia da gaming,
anche il ragazzo tenderà a comprare
tali oggetti per assomigliare al suo idolo
che diventa persino
quasi un miglior amico.
Però, abbiamo anche
delle sponsorizzazioni,
quindi, non siamo influenzati
solo dai Creator
ma siamo influenzati
anche da ciò che vediamo sui social,
quindi ciò che vediamo tra le storie,
ció che vediamo nei post
chiaramente può influenzare
la nostra decisione d’acquisto,
e magari ci sono delle generazioni
un po’ più anziane, le quali tendono
a pensare che la piattaforma li ascolti
mentre stiano facendo altre attività
e quindi proponga determinati prodotti
proprio perché li ha ascoltati.
In realtà all’interno dei social
c’è una profilazione e un’analisi perfetta
di tutto ciò che facciamo,
le interazioni e tutte le nostre azioni
all’interno della piattaforma
porteranno a una decisione
di mostrarci determinati annunci
rispetto ad altri.
Quindi, non è che ci stanno effettivamente
ascoltando ma sanno esattamente
quali sono i nostri interessi
e sapranno che oggi vorrò comprare
una determinata televisione e non un’altra
o comprare una lampada rispetto ad altre.
Tutta questa analisi e questa profilazione
che è fatta da parte delle piattaforme,
da parte degli algoritmi
sulla nostra identità
e su ciò che sono i nostri interessi
porterà a una Filter Bubble,
ovvero una bolla che ci circonda
e che va a contenere i nostri interessi.
Questo può portare dei rischi
se non abbiamo la consapevolezza
di sapere cos’è questa Filter Bubble.
Quindi, se noi ad esempio,
vediamo solo determinati argomenti
e vediamo solo una posizione
ad esempio in politica,
vediamo un lato della medaglia
e non vediamo l’altro,
non sapremo mai esattamente qual è l’idea
e quali sono i pensieri della controparte
e quindi tenderemo ad essere
sempre più estremisti.
Infatti già nel 2010,
l’autore del libro “Filter Bubble”
andava un po’ a preannunciare
quello che sarebbe stato questo problema.
Faceva riferimento soprattutto a Google
che al momento era già molto grande
e andava a diciamo schedulare,
a personalizzare ciò che veniva mostrato
a ogni singolo utente
che aveva la propria personalizzazione
dei motori di ricerca
e di ciò che veniva cercato
all’interno della piattaforma.
Questo può essere un grande problema
e per quello dobbiamo essere consapevoli
di ciò che stiamo guardando
e capire che oltre a quello che vediamo
nel social c’è tutt’un altro mondo
che magari quello che vedo io
non è quello che vedi te
e quello che vedi te.
Ognuno vede una parte della piattaforma,
dobbiamo andare a analizzare
e scoprire che c’è tutt’altro mondo
sempre all’interno dello stesso social.
Ma i social come guadagnano?
Penso che molti di voi lo sappiano.
Guadagnano attraverso i nostri dati,
quindi guadagnano attraverso la conoscenza
e proprio questa profilazione,
che viene fatto del nostro profilo.
Noi siamo diventati a tutti gli effetti
il prodotto che viene venduto dai brand
a le persone e ai brand stessi
decisi a investire nella piattaforma.
Quindi andremo a vendere
degli spazi pubblicitari
presenti all’interno del nostro feed
e verrà mostrata a me una pubblicità
e a voi tutt’altra, proprio perché sa
esattamente quali sono i nostri interessi,
quindi sa che rispetto magari a investire
nei media tradizionali come, ad esempio,
la televisione con un pubblico generalista
e non sappiamo esattamente in cosa
stiamo investendo, all’interno dei social
si sa esattamente di cosa stiamo parlando
e di cosa vogliamo investire.
Di conseguenza noi siamo diventati
il prodotto che Facebook
o qualsiasi altro brand va a vendere
all’interno dei social.
Per questo la Generazione Z sta diventando
sempre più attenta alla privacy
quindi non mi stupirei se in futuro
il prossimo social che prenderà il posto
di quelli attuali sarà un social
dove al primo posto metterà la privacy,
ossia trasparenza di tutte le informazioni
e tutti i dati che vengono utilizzati
all’interno della piattaforma.
Un altro problema sicuramente dei social
è quello delle fake news.
Quindi, tutto ciò che leggiamo
sui social, non è perfetto
e non è per forza
ciò che rispecchia la realtà.
Infatti abbiamo, nei media tradizionali
come ad esempio la televisione,
le generazioni passate sono abituate
a vedere notizie verificate da giornalisti
appartenenti a un albo e di conseguenza
devono seguire delle effettive regole
se no verranno radiati.
Mentre sui social ognuno può dire la sua,
dire cosa ne pensa e creare notizie.
E questo provoca sicuramente dei problemi
anche perché molto spesso per aumentare
i click al sito, si va a creare dei titoli
spesso finti che vengono detti clickbait
e quindi magari una persona
non va ad approfondire
e legge semplicemente il titolo
questo farà sì che non sappiamo
esattamente cosa è successo ma porterà
a una conoscenza, a un’ignoranza
soprattutto su quell’argomento
e quindi si inizierà a diffondere,
e creerà dei gravi problemi in società.
Moltissima parte della generazione passata
pensa che i social siano perdita di tempo,
ma questo non è sempre così .
Sui social possiamo apprendere competenze,
si possono apprendere skill
che poi potremo andare a rivendere
sul mercato del lavoro,
quindi, ad esempio, nel mio caso stesso
io ho imparato moltissime cose
grazie ai social
e questo mi ha permesso
di creare un nuovo lavoro.
Così come i Creator visti,
abbiamo i Social Media Manager
e i Social Media Strategist,
abbiamo chi crea le sponsorizzazioni
all’interno della piattaforma.
Di conseguenza sono nati moltissimi lavori
grazie al mondo dei social,
quindi non sono completamente
una perdita di tempo.
Chiaramente, ci vuole la consapevolezza,
e capire esattamente
cosa stiamo facendo all’interno dei social
perché se usati come utenti passivi
o diventando vittime di queste piattaforme
rischiamo di avere problemi psicologici
oppure di procrastinazione per sempre
all’interno di questi social
quindi dobbiamo stare molto attenti.
La Generazione Z non solo usa i social
come strumento di conoscenza
ma anche legandosi molto a cause sociali.
Infatti, in questo esempio vediamo
il Friday for Futures, nato sui social,
si è espanso molto anche grazie ai social
dove le persone si riuniscono
per manifestare, cercando di modificare
il cambiamento climatico,
cercando di avere parte
a questo progetto, a questo movimento.
E sicuramente i social prendono parte
perché quando l’utente va a manifestazioni
decide di andare a prendere parte
a questo progetto, lo condivide sui social
e ricondivide il pensiero
di chi la pensa come lui, come ad esempio,
Greta Thunberg pubblica molto questi temi,
molte persone condividono la propria idea
che si diffonde grazie ai social,
quindi i social sono sicuramente un mezzo
anche per andare a diffondere notizie
e movimenti positivi e cause sociali.
Altro esempio è Black Lives Matter
nel quale dopo la morte di George Floyd
in America, moltissimi utenti
si sono avvicinati a questa causa.
Charli D’Amelio che è la TikToker
più famosa al mondo su TikTok
ha deciso di inserire come foto profilo
“Black Lives Matter”,
e la tenuta per quasi un anno e mezzo.
Moltissimi utenti hanno inserito
come foto profilo il logo del movimento
cercando effettivamente di prendere parte
e non solo passivamente,
quindi dicendo agli amici: “Secondo me
è una cosa buona e dovremo seguirla tutti”
ma anche facendosi portavoce
in prima persona di questo movimento.
Inoltre su TikTok soprattutto, e quindi
anche sui social per la Generazione Z,
vi è un avvicinamento alla Body Positivity
ovvero cercando di andare a eliminare
quel problema che si è creato moltissimo
con Instagram dove moltissime persone
creano contenuti utilizzando applicazioni
esterne, piattaforme che permettono
di essere sempre perfetti
anche appena svegliati,
e quindi noi iniziamo a pensare
che siamo noi sbagliati
e che le persone che vediamo
sui social non hanno difetti.
In realtà abbiamo scoperto grazie a TikTok
che questo non è sempre così,
per i più piccoli è un punto fondamentale,
infatti moltissime persone
appartenenti a questa generazione
hanno deciso di mostrare i propri difetti,
mostrare le proprie imperfezioni nei video
così le persone sanno che non siamo noi
a essere sbagliati, semplicemente,
quello che vediamo non è la realtà.
Quindi i social sono una minaccia
o un’opportunità?
Sicuramente i social possono essere
un’opportunità se utilizzati
con la giusta consapevolezza e cercando
di capire sempre cosa stiamo facendo
e conoscendo in modo approfondito
il social stesso.
Se non seguiamo queste regole può invece
diventare una grandissima minaccia
portando problemi
sia a livello sociale che psicologico,
pensando che noi siamo sbagliati
e confrontandoci con persone
che vivono dall’altra parte del mondo
e sembrano perfette,
noi abbiamo dei difetti.
In realtà tutti abbiamo difetti, e avere
questa consapevolezza è importantissimo.
Quindi, andiamo a vedere tre consigli,
per essere meno boomer sui social.
Sicuramente, bisogna approfondire
informazioni quando noi leggiamo il titolo
ma dobbiamo andare a cercare
qual è quella notizia,
andare a approfondire su fonti autorevoli
e cercare di capire chi ne sta parlando,
è una persona che è iscritta all’albo,
quindi è un giornalista
o una persona che ha messo un post
su Instagram o su Facebook
e ha deciso che per lui
quella è la verità.
Approfondire sempre le informazioni.
Inoltre non giudicare e odiare o insultare
persone che troviamo online
solo perché non ci piace quel contenuto,
ma cerchiamo di capire che quella persona
dietro lo schermo è come noi,
quindi ha dei sentimenti,
e se noi la insultiamo,
commentando con l’odio quella persona,
anche quella persona ha sentimenti
e si può offendere e sentirsi male.
Quindi, capire che chi è dietro lo schermo
è come noi, una persona reale.
Infine studiare i canali,
quindi cercare di capire come funzionano,
analizzarli e avere una consapevolezza
di come funzionano i social.
Capire bene che algoritmo ci sta dietro.
Capire perché mi vengono determinati post,
così come magari ad altre persone
vengono altri post
e quindi capire effettivamente
come funzionano i social.
Finendo i social sono luoghi dove persone
possono esprimersi senza barriere.
Di conseguenza, non dobbiamo più vederli
come un luogo del male
oppure una perdita di tempo.
Ormai fanno parte delle nostre vite,
quindi il mio consiglio
è quello di approfondirli e studiarli,
perché se studiato in modo approfondito
possono portarci delle nuove opportunità
cambiare la nostra vita in meglio
e ridurre questo svantaggio
e questa differenza
che c’è tra le generazioni.
Grazie. (Applauso)